what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel so
the reason i look a mess right now is
because i was quite literally in bed and
i thought of this video idea
and i just couldn't get it out of my
head i swear to god i couldn't so i was
like you know what
i am going to show you
i'm going to start by saying i am tired
of the lizzo shaming
i like lizzo
and the manosphere just cannot get over
the fact that she's heavy and this is i
i saw this video of chisha's ads
and it really summarizes the issue so
let me let me just for the top
like four percent of you know guys in
the top like
small percentage of guys out there who
are tall it's just kind of ridiculous
you're definitely missing out on
opportunities even celebrities aren't
that delusional at the end of the day
you know what i mean yeah
but yeah
uh but liz always because she tried to
uh d uh hit on captain america anyways
okay like what i'm sorry you can't score
if you don't shoot
she
let the woman shoot her shot obviously
he's gonna say no like clearly but just
okay i'm gonna continue what do you got
against lizzo i don't have anything
against lizzo man i have no problem with
lizzo but i do have a problem with her
um
wait
just say it wait
coining her whole like
she she calls her whole who movement
like this body positivity and like
equality
acceptance thing
when the truth is
i i don't see that it's not about that
it's about she wants to not be called
fat she wants special treatment
for example i'll tell you how i know
this
there's a video of dj khaled that was
posted on the shade room and he's
listening to a drake song right he's in
the back of the car and he's like
dancing and stuff you know what he does
you know what i mean um when he's doing
his thing
and his shirts off and he's having a
good time he's confident i go in the
comments
i think it was all death was the first
person who said um if jello was a person
you know like they they commented that
and then the rest of the comments is
just these brutal man they're just
clowning them all throughout the comment
section and i said oh man where's lizzo
you know what i mean to come save dj
khaled she doesn't care man she doesn't
give a [ __ ]
you know
people don't care about body shaming
when it comes to men it's not about
equality because if it was about
equality then somebody would have said
in that comment section hey guys this is
wrong you know dj khaled we shouldn't
talk to him like that but no if it's
rick ross if it's dj khaled they're
getting all the smoke buy a brand i was
surprised that a brand actually started
to smoke off they said all right i'm
gonna kick it off boom
you know but you'd never see a brand
saying that about
lizzo because you know women want
special treatment not equality
i think women are more sensitive to
those things okay let's
clearly i'm going to put all of you guys
on clearly you guys have not watched
this video so let me just show you
[Applause]
[Music]
hey boy what you say boy you're trying
to play koi like a game boy hit my phone
boy is your homeboy are you alone boy
come get me down boy got a boy with
degrees a boy in the streets a boy on
his knees he a man in the sheets sheesh
it's all greek to me got this boy
speaking spanish
baby i don't need you
i just wanna freak you
i heard you a freak too
[Music]
and there's a point just waiting
[Music]
i like big boys itty bitty boys
mississippi boys inner city boys i like
the pretty boys with the bowtie get your
nails dead let it blow dry i like a big
beard i like a clean face i don't
discriminate come and get a taste from
the playboys to the gay boys go and slay
boy
boys you cannot say
try not to be too loud because my
brother is asleep you cannot say that
lizzo does not represent
the big boys i like big boys skinny boys
she
body positivity
at i have no doubt that lizard does not
want to be called fat no doubt
but let's let's give credit where credit
is due and let's let's listen to the
rest of this fire song
baby i don't need you
[Music]
two plus two
[Music]
go crazy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
anyways
all i'm saying
all i'm saying is let's give credit
let's give credit where credit is due
i stan lizzo
now what i'm not saying
is that i'm with all the body positivity
i'm not even saying like there's pros
and cons to the movement like
i see some pluses like
some of the models early 2000s
were unhealthily skinny we can agree on
that like crazy thin
early 2000s like hip bones
i'm not built like that guys i'd have to
starve myself for a while
for you to see my hip bones
anyways
i like big boys a fire song
let me know in the comments if you guys
agree or disagree but
the case the case for lizzo